[موسيقى]
اني كيف ان انا حبيت اعطي صوتي اني حبيت
انطي اللي بداخلي اريد اعبر اريد احد يسمع
صوتي
ليش اخترت هاي الصوره ابدا يحاول ينقذ
طفلته
بشكل مؤلم يعني يعرف انه جسدها بارد يعرف
انه هي ميته بس مع هذا ماسك ايدها حتى
يحسسها بالامان حنان الابوه ليحسسها ان هو
موجود يمها كل شوي تسمع فقدان اقرب شخص لك
وماذا يقدر ماذا تقدر تسوي شي
بشكل مؤلم يعني هذا زلزال اخذ منه اعز ما
علينا بس ما قدرنا نسوي اي شيء
[موسيقى]
منك انا اكون بمكانها حتى احس بحنان
الابوه
يا ميته بس يحس الانسان يحس باي شكل يحس
لما يكون اب ساندها لما يكون ابي كورياها
لو حتى شخص ما يتحس اني انا عندي ثقه بهذا
الشيء حنان الابوه غير اللي ما عاش بس
يفهم
لانه حسيتها دخلت القلب هاي نفس قصتي
تقريبا بس اصلا ماكو فرق بيننا وبين بين
الميتين اللي في الزلازل اللي بداخلنا
ذاته
جسديا واحنا ميتين زعتر الروحانيه انا
عندي هوايه من اللوحات بس مع الاسف وقت
اللي زلازل
نقذت قدرت انقذ يعني كلهم فقدتهم بس قدرت
انقذ منهم ثلاثه بس هذه هي لوحات اللي
حابه اتبرع بيهم الضحايا الزلزال وبس هذول
اللي قدرتم
[موسيقى]